okay I just learned the greatest life
hack if you see something that you want
to take a picture of but you left your
phone at home don't worry just do this
blindfold yourself for like 30 minutes
and then stare at what you want to take
a picture of for 3 minutes next pull out
one of your eyeballs and cut it in half
top to bottom throw the back half into a
14% potassic Alum solution within 24
hours the ropson on your retina will
become fixed into a permanent image of
the last thing you were looking at it's
called an optogram
and no one's ever done it at least not
to themselves the process was invented
in the late 1800s here's an optogram
from the Reta of a rabbit that was
forced to stare at a window now at the
turn of the century this caused a lot of
excitement optogram might help us solve
crimes right we could look at the eyes
of victims and see the last thing they
saw unfortunately optogram are of very
poor quality here's one from the retina
of a rabbit that looked at a picture of
Salvador DOI their poor quality means
they have no forensic value so keep your
eyes in their sockets